The biggest opportunity for copywriters
today is not being a copywriter. People
don't care about writing copy, okay?
Especially in today's age where they
think copywriting is a commodity and
that AI can do it. [music] What they
care about, what other people care
about, is the sales medium that gets
them more money, all right? And those
three mediums that people mostly care
about is email, social media, and
landing [music] pages. What you need to
do as a copywriter is not sell
copywriting. You need to sell the
ability to convert on one of those sales
mediums. The people want you to do that
for them and how you do that, they don't
care. They don't care. They don't even
need to know that you write copy. You
need to know that the secret sauce to
you being able to do that is
copywriting. You don't got to tell
people, you don't got to brag that only
copywriters care. Pick a medium, master
it.